[Musique]
d'ici là d'après la nahb y compris a été
appelé par tf1 et comme toute la france
faut faire danse avec les stars
alors on sait pas si elle fera danseuse
ou star mais elle a été appelée
capucines à la sagesse et le conseil de
famille venez donner votre avis capucine
nous dira vaut aussi chez vous est-ce
que vous pensez que capucine adav doit
quitter touche pas à mon poste est allé
rejoindre le casting de dalles ce même
si tous les deux on peut pas être au
four et au moulin d'andé cyril la
question c'est est-ce que si elle va
vous la reprenait après voilà c'est ça
côté géorgien vous savez mon ex à fait
la même chose et aujourd'hui et avec
laurent romejko vous me poserez toutes
les questions après elle pendant que
vous donnez votre analyse est ce qu'on
pensait qu'elle doit aller faire dans
cette histoire ou pas sachez qu'ils ont
proposé 100 mille euros a pas six cent
mille euros
astronomie et à l 2 millions proposés la
magnifique somme de 250 euros
et une paire de babouches
oui mais qu'est ce que vous voulez la
ballon et tout à l'heure c'est super
quand même par laurette tout à l'heure
c'est le conseil de famille va donner
leur avis d'accord et on sait que c'est
vrai qu'à puisque vous l'avez dit
vous-même
nous avons appelé sinon il faut qu'on
avec mathieu et elle a été confirmée
d'aspa bon mathieu on était tous les
deux dans la loge exactement en train de
changer elle a dit ça voilà c'est un ami
non non c'est bon c'est bon allez c'est
bon merci on fera aussi le fauteuil qui
se retourne oui bien sûr si le fauteuil
se retourne c'est que les gens veulent
que vous restiez montée pmp j'aimerais
avant la vie de nos invités stomie et
pacy est ce qu'on pensait qu'elle doit y
allait quitter tnp est allé faire dans
cette les stars c'est vraiment dense
exercé quatre mois ouais lp mp c'est
toute l'année ouais mais il a par après
toi maintenant mais si si et lima presse
sur tp mp3 oui mais à fall reste sur les
pmp les gars on n'a pas encore signé de
contrat l'année prochaine
tanaka puis alors j'aimerais avoir
l'avis de mme à gagny alors oui ça
m'agace et faisons la danse est un petit
peu sale affaire dans sa peau avec elle
tout à l'heure on va voir si non mais
c'est vrai il a raison ce tome i il a
raison et pour tomber j'adore ce gars
enfin danser alors magali vocal que vous
êtes bien sur deux de télé star on aime
les télémistes à orem télé star qui font
un bon boulot
sans déconner c'est vrai alors alors oui
à 100 pour 100 kwh à 100 pour soi le
quitter pompey bande rory parce que
comme ça va libérer la place pendant
quatre mois et puis je pourrait postuler
[Applaudissements]
à
j'ai envie d'aller fouiller français par
les français 20 ans le français va merci
rhin tarbes à gilles verdez qu'elle
partait vite sa déco les capucines elle
est instable
elle va donne en sommes il faut qu'elle
ait des missions l'émission elle se
cherche elle est en quête d'identité va
pas d'homo nomme et si je peux me
permettre à mon avis capucine à la je
pense qu'elle devrait faire dense avec
des fils de stars
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite sur une rumba capucine
haddad est le fils de laurent fabius la
télé fils de montréal a envie que tu peu
de lumière je trouve qu'elle devrait
martyrs on sait qu'elle doit parcourir 3
de jean michel maire non moi je pense
qu'il faut rester parce que déjà grâce à
vous enfin il ya un peu à l'émission
elle progresse de semaine en semaine à
haut niveau car oui en général bon je
pense que dans 2 3 ans pour la présenter
au brevet donc je pensais déjà
[Musique]
et de gauche auquel un peu tendre pour
avoir une sorte d' ambition au groupe
tf1 qu'elle fasse ces armes ici après
peut-être tf1 mais là je vois pas qu'on
puisse le confie l'émission a tf1 on
donne dans le groupe rien n'est pas
tellement de classe que pour les ténors
mathieu de leur 4 4
j'ai donc départager algérien départager
du clip avec toute l'affection que j'ai
pour elle justement parce que de
l'affection pour elle il faut qu'elle y
aille et qu'elle y aille absolument pour
trois raisons la première c'est son rêve
faut toujours su ses rêves c'est un jour
son rêve c'est vraiment son arrivée
c'est vraiment ça fait trois ans qu'elle
parle que de cette émission
et c'est vrai qu'avant il se murmurait
un petit peu on me l'a dit parce qu'ils
étaient à prendre benoît et à tf1 ce
qu'on avait dix est temps que les gens
soient nrj12 ils ne viendront pas faire
danse avec les stars donc à son temps
qu'elle était à nrj où c'était mort
question d'image imagine maintenant
qu'elle est assez vite elle peut en
revanche y aller il ya plus de preuve
dimanche la deuxième raison c'est que
vous êtes un peu honnête c'est quoi la
suite pour l année prochaine au mieux
elle est chroniqueuse encore dans tpm
paix mais je suis pas certain certains
cas les prochaines ce but va lui donner
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup dans leur
démission et tout ça est la troisième
raison c'est que nt1 est une chaîne qui
devient complètement la télé réalité tf1
aussi les petites choses je pense que
vraiment ils peuvent le trouver d une
place sur sur tf1 ou sur nt1 sans aucun
problème dans le groupe et c'est un
grand groupe total rêve aussi donc
franchement le real est donc vous pensez
qu'elle doit y aller ah oui capucine
déjà c'est vrai qu'ils vous ont appelé
on l'a vu on le sait avec mathieu et
j'avais des infos de tf1 je sais qu'il
vous aura plu pour faire danse avec les
stars
capucine qu'est ce que vous avez envie
de faire dit la vérité déjà j'aimerais
répondre à mathieu parce qu'il dit que
je suis en et sur nrj 12 il nous
appellerons pas faux puisqu'ils m'ont
appelé l'année dernière j'ai passé le
casting et je suis levée dès que tu
avais déjà quitté nrj douche l'appui
remercie pour cet homme c'est un
paramètre dont on soupçonnait pas eu
d'appel a été vraiment non non mais plus
éminents la production qui m'appelait
qui m'a dit comme l'année dernière oui
bon de rappeler mais c'est pas on ne
sait pas où on sait que c'est vrai a ri
si j'aime jouer sur les baux est ce que
vous avez envie d'y aller ou pas dieu
mais non mais c'est amel est sûre ils
vont proposer il me propose réellement
parce qu'il voulons proposer arrêter de
dire des bêtises vous nous l'avez dit à
mathieu on ment pas aux téléspectateurs
mais franchement oui on en a besoin mais
c'est bon alors ok bah j'aimerais y
aller
si jamais je te dire vous acceptez
que je sois quand même la une à deux
fois par semaine pendant que vous faites
dans sa crise tard chez camille soit
chez vous c'est à dire c'est à dire j'ai
pas envie de quitter la chaîne et niveau
d'ailleurs coûté donc vous êtes en train
de me dire qu'ils avaient mangé à tous
les atouts
[Applaudissements]
elle va me traiter comme un moins que
rien or il s'agit là mais fait scandale
au malin veut lever la crémière ont été
entamées il ya veut le beurre et le cul
de la crémière
tout est là et on sait que le beurre ou
le plus la camair que les deux merci
alors capucines à naves
oui donc vous voudriez faire touche pas
à mon poste et faire danse avec les
stars et faire il en pense quoi
non mais tu vois je suis ta merde oui
j'aimerais marquer quatre mois dans
danse avec les stars parce que je suis
jeune et que je peux faire les aussi
veut dire que moi donc franchement donc
je servirai la soupe à tf1 je paye
quelqu'un ici et tf1 ils sont
tranquilles rouler vendredi soir elle va
danser la balle va faire la belle mais
moi je la récupère ici voilà et vice
versa abb mallory journal à [ __ ] tout
ça ne s'appellera pas une personne alors
jolie s cadence bien c'est seulement
alors les chéris la région aride avec
sage a fait une démonstration
si la machine
tu lançais qu'elle
[Musique]
ok
en
comme les mais il a fait une tête quand
on ya cru alors c'est que ça couine une
base faut du travail encore mais y'a
plus rester minimum deux mois inch'allah
kapil sibal à jean franchement non c'est
pas mal mais elle est dense mieux que ce
que je pensais
ah ouais ouais parce que je croyais que
vous dansiez comme une merde capucine ah
oui non l'instant on verra la vie ah oui
les internautes et je vous donnerai ma
réponse est ce que j'accepte que vous
fassiez danse avec les stars étaient pmp
pas la peine de me regarder comme ça je
suis le fils de personnes a tout de
suite
sur ces 8 je vais donner mon avis oui
mais avant que vous donniez votre avion
jamais je devais tout n'entend rien bah
ne le fait plus alors je vais vous dire
dans cette émission j'ai toujours été
juste et il n'y a pas deux poids deux
mesures bien j'avais dit à mathieu s'il
partait s'annonçait questa
malheureusement ne pourrait pas le
garder non non ça que j'attendais un
banquier matthieu as un paquet bien n'a
alors pas deux poids deux mesures
rappelle roger tout un n'avait pas le
même âge mais vous avez la même connerie
c'est pour ça que vous êtes non les
chéris malheureusement malheureusement
on peut pas être au pg et être prêté six
mois à l'om et revenir au pays bah oui
voilà c'est dit klein c'est bien mais
c'est vrai on est pas et on est où
c'est un bordel à la téloche donc je
vous aime beaucoup
je vous suivrez dans danse avec les
stars si vous devez y aller
on se reverra mais je pourrais pas faire
les deux en même temps peut-être après
le pas d'accord non venir pas ici à
l'accueil
[Applaudissements]
en plus je passerai mon mais entre
l'année prochaine comme ça merci à
gignac tout cas éviter l'humour dans
danse avec les stars
capucine maintenant rio pour moi c'est
non 1
on va voir si les téléspectateurs
veulent marquer danse avec les stars
si le fauteuil se retourne alors
maintenant sachez le le fauteuil est
électrique c'est un truc de ouf ça nous
a coûté une fortune c'est comme si le
fauteuil ne se retourne pas c'est que
les gens veulent que vous alliez dans
danse avec les stars 2 6 3
ça fait deux
résultat
[Musique]
la chine comptait quitter pour rejoindre
danse avec les stars oui à 61 % et non à
31 content donc le fauteuil ne se
retourne pas capucine apparemment les
gens les gens ont vu pouvoir danser
questar c'est pas qu'ils veulent vous
voir quitter tnp ce qu'ils veulent vous
voir danser et surtout avec la
démonstration que la fête
je peux vous dire même moi qui ai envie
que vous restiez j'ai quand même envie
je vous faire danser même si vous restez
ici vous non c'est le mot le dit merci
capucines à la presse donc la petite
juste dernière son look si si si c'est
si c'est confirmé vous faites quoi fait
quoique a pu je reste avec vous je pense
sera à nantes
eh bah oui bâle a pris sa décision reste
à les tirer est ce que le public
souhaite que certains restent quand même
pas mal ici bas aujourd'hui albert
j'adore